eu trabalho com o coração que o órgão
incrível a partir de mais ou menos 12
semanas de gestação ele já está pronto
pra não ter nutrir todos os demais
órgãos do nosso corpo nos permite ver
crescer amar ser felizes e isso ele faz
mais de três bilhões de vezes numa vida
em média
geralmente silenciosamente sem nos dar
trabalho infelizmente em torno de uma em
cada dez crianças em cada 100 crianças
que nascem e se coraçãozinho ele vem com
uma malformação pessoas como eu na
verdade trabalho em dar diagnóstico
dessas malformações e quando nós
identificamos uma malformação grave
muitas vezes são coisas simples mas
quando a gente identifica uma formação
grave a gente sabe que vai passar por um
é muito longo esses lares não têm a
idéia de forma alguma de chocá los mas
essa é a realidade de um bebê com doença
cardíaca pra nóis cardiologistas na
verdade esse rapazinho tá ótimo
ele está curado ele tabém perfundidos
ele passou por um cirurgia enorme mas
logo logo como aconteceu de verdade vai
estar de volta nos braços dos pais e
indo bem mas nós trabalhamos no terceiro
mundo nós trabalhamos na região e
desenvolvimento e muitas vezes as
crianças não chegam dessa forma essa
mocinha que está do lado dele tinha a
mesma doença também passou por uma
cirurgia cardíaca mas do pós operatório
preciso passar um tempo muito longo na
uti e não por conta do problema cardíaco
mas por conta da situação em que nos
chega de desnutrição extrema essa é a
realidade que nós que trabalhamos com o
coração
nesta parte do mundo vivemos e é muito
difícil orquestrar as fases que essas
pessoas precisam passar em qualquer uma
dessas duas mas evidentemente muito mais
naquela criança que vem mais sofrida é
como se a gente tivesse que votar uma
grande orquestra para funcionar ea gente
acredita que onde há um desejo há um
caminho mas a gente sabe que muitas
vezes é difícil é como se você tivesse
que montar uma grande orquestra sem ter
todos os músicos sem os músicos estar
treinando sem ter todos os instrumentos
necessários
isso é muito mais difícil ainda porque a
gente hoje vive num mundo completamente
globalizado não é verdade a gente tem
resposta pré moldada para tudo então
onde tem um problema alguém já tenha
solução pronta ao problema da solução às
vezes dá
certo mas às vezes não é exatamente isso
que a gente vê alguns problemas são
menores as soluções não encaixam maiores
e tudo será que às vezes algumas dessas
soluções não estão sendo desenhadas por
pessoas que nem viveram os problemas ea
gente está tentando adaptar essas
soluções
e aí a gente se pergunta e se nós
pudéssemos fazer diferente e se nós
pudéssemos montar a orquestra se nós
pudéssemos identificar qual a melhor
música para tocar naquela situação
quando os melhores músicos qual o seu
talento e na verdade trabalhar junto
esses indivíduos para encontrar soluções
nós acreditamos que isso pode ser feitos
na verdade nós costumamos chamar a isso
os legos pelo acrônimo de liderar
empoderando os grupos para otimizar
solução soluções mas também realmente
pela idéia do brinquedo a idéia de
tentar ir montando soluções através de
pequenos blocos onde a gente antes de
tudo o que coloca as pessoas em conjunto
agrupa as pessoas forma grupos para
analisar o problema e aí na verdade
seria empoderadas com as ferramentas
necessárias essas ferramentas pode ser a
tecnologia pode ser em algum aspecto e
disse numa das muitas vezes é uma
cultura diferente é aquela cultura que
faz com que as pessoas se sintam com a
participantes co responsáveis e que
todos numa cadeia todos na equipe de
trabalho se sintam responsáveis pela
solução final daquele modelo que pode
até não ser o modelo que a gente estava
pensando a solução que a gente estava
pensando pode tomar outras formas podem
ser diferentes mas que talvez seja muito
melhor para aquela situação que nós
estamos enfrentando então eu vim aqui
hoje para falar pra vocês de uma
experiência legos que se iniciou seis
anos atrás entre dois estados do
nordeste do brasil
um deles que não tinha na época ainda
uma estrutura para tratar crianças com
problemas cardíacos
então nós tínhamos na verdade uma região
com mais ou menos 4 milhões de
habitantes 56 mil quilômetros quadrados
e tínhamos que identificar os músicos da
orquestra para trabalhar juntos
a primeira etapa é claro foi conectar
esses músicos o que fizemos como a rede
de telemedicina nenhuma tecnologia
diferente de tudo que já existe mas
conectamos vários centros para trabalhar
juntos depois desenvolvemos uma
ferramenta porque esses centros
pudessem se comunicar para que essas
pessoas se pudesse se comunicar e
desenvolvemos naturalmente é tecnologias
de informática e principalmente um banco
de dados para que nós pudéssemos
prospectivamente acompanhar tudo o que
acontecia com as crianças que iríamos
estar avaliando depois desenvolvemos
também os protocolos para estruturar a
rede
iniciando com os protocolos mas básicos
para que todas as pessoas que pudessem
participar entender se o modelo depois
trabalhando especificamente na área de
cardiologia e fazendo protocolos para as
enfermeiras que fazem uma triagem básica
quando o bebê nasce
e a gente sabe que temos enfermeiras em
todas as maternidades
depois quando essas crianças pelas
enfermeiras parecem ter algum tipo de
problema elas passam por uma segunda
triagem onde médico pediatra faz um
exame do coração sendo guiado por
telemedicina dentro daquela rede por um
cardiologista
depois estabelecemos três ambulatórios
no estado para que a gente pudesse
acompanhar essas crianças e finalmente a
nossa equipe cirúrgica concordou em se
deslocar uma vez por semana para fazer
as cirurgias dos bebês identificados
a orquestra começou a tocar em janeiro
de 2012
estamos com aproximadamente seis anos de
trabalho conjunto
nesse período a equipe fez um trabalho
de triagem de nível onde quase 180
bebezinhos de se sair mais ou menos 2%
achou que poderia ter problemas
cardíacos e pediu a triagem de nível 2
ea cada dois desses um bebê foi
identificado
mostrando como a gente quando organiza o
recurso humano dentro do sistema de
saúde
a gente consegue melhores resultados
muitos atendimentos clínicos foram
feitos e mais de 500 cirurgias o que
ainda é bem aquém daquilo que nós
gostaríamos mas muito mais do que tinha
sido feito até então quando nós fomos
olhar os resultados muito rapidamente a
gente viu que esse estado se uma
detecção de doenças cardíacas que era
inferior àquelas reportadas ao
continente pelo continente africano
depois que a rede com o metrô começou a
trabalhar em equipe
o nível de detecção subiu pra ficar
semelhante à américa do norte semelhante
à europa dentro do mesmo estado
mas aí nessa fase nós vimos que só
estávamos pegando as crianças pequenas
e como modelo
recusei um modelo plástico nós
discutimos como fazer pra pegar crianças
maiores e aí a primeira inovação se
chamou caravana do coração
uma grande ação onde vários
profissionais segue para visitar e triar
crianças no estado essa inovação também
mudou muito e saiu da cardiologia para
várias outras áreas
deixou de ser somente cardiologia para
outras áreas de surdos e somente
assistência para também cuidar de
capacitação de vários profissionais
muitas coisas acontecem essa caravana é
tão carismática que você precisa falar
pra sentir tem pessoas que acham que a
caravana é toda a rede na verdade e dela
surgiram muitos projetos novos como
famílias do coração um grupo de pessoas
que através da música
procurou repassar conceitos de saúde
para essas famílias e trabalhar um pouco
o lado educativo o lado social deles
juntos mas a caravana quando nós fomos
no interior descobrimos um outro
problema também era difícil para aquelas
crianças que moravam lá na ponta
chegarem até os ambulatórios que nós
tínhamos estabelecido nas três cidades
principais e aí foi novamente feito uma
discussão e uma nova inovação veio à
tona chama-se ecotáxi o que é um eco tax
nós abrimos novas salas do coração em
cada uma daquelas cidades pequenas onde
o trabalho da rede realizado
chamamos os médicos e os enfermeiros
fizemos um treinamento e em seguida
compramos três lotes de equipamentos de
cardiologia e colocamos em malas grandes
essas malas na verdade nós colocamos
para seguirem no estado na primeira
semana cada uma vai para três cidades
mais três na segunda na terceira semana
na quarta semana em um mês
doze novos ambulatórios de cardiologia
são realizados com apenas três lotes de
equipamentos com supervisão por
telemedicina e com isso muitas crianças
que precisavam se deslocar e não mais o
fazem no estado e conseguem ter sua
assistência localmente
dentro disso o que outras expansões
dentro dessa rede
ela começou com cardiologia mas logo nós
vimos que podíamos ajudar outras
crianças
isso tem origem em uma rede de pele na
tecnologia onde hoje todas as crianças
que nascem têm uma supervisão de um
pediatra que fica também por
telemedicina trabalhando eles fazem
capacitação fazem treinamento fazem
regulação mas o filme recentemente
esse assunto em 2015 a rede teve um
outro grande desafio é exatamente o
surto de microcefalia a paraíba foi o
segundo estado mais afetado por esse
problema e essa equipe se reuniu e fez
um treinamento para que aquilo que
estava sendo feito para cardiologia
pudesser passado a ser feito pelas
crianças como microcefalia que agora são
seguidas pela rede
dentro desse ambiente poderia dizer
muitas coisas a respeito dessa rede um
banco de dados de quase 200 mil crianças
talvez um dos maiores nessa parte do
mundo em questão de dados médicos mas eu
queria rapidamente mudar o fogo antes de
encerrar para tentar passar para vocês
um pouco o dia a dia do que é viver essa
rede e no domingo enquanto estava
pensando no que dizer aqui hoje eu
recebi uma mensagem que foi rapidamente
passar para vocês são textos mais
cansativos mas eu vou dizer rapidamente
o que aconteceu eu recebi uma mensagem
no skype pedindo ajuda sobre um paciente
existem ambientes próprios de rede mas
principalmente finais de semana e à
noite se usa o skype usando motos ap
eu passei adiante foi ver de onde vinha
essa mensagem de um pontinho lá adiante
uma cidade de 20 mil habitantes no
interior do estado uma criança
extremamente grave
eu passei então um pedido para que as
pessoas pudessem nos ajudar com essa
criança eu peço a vocês a atenção o
horário isso é um domingo de manhã às
nove e meia da manhã
oito minutos depois várias pessoas
estavam respondendo e já tinham ligado
pra fazer contato
a gente segue com isso aí e com mais ou
menos 20 minutos ea gente já tinha uma
vaga liberada no hospital grande de
pediatria os colegas continuam
conversando discutindo coisas sérias uma
situação dificílima essa criança era
filha de outra criança mantinha 14 anos
e uma situação extremamente difícil do
ponto de vista social a colega chefe da
cardiologia já tinha visto o diagnóstico
já estava ajudando o tratamento da
criança em torno de uma hora e 56
minutos para ser exato
nove profissionais de medicina estavam
envolvidos ajudando essa criança e em
três horas
a criança via estava a otimizada já
havia saído daquela cidade para
percorrer um caminho que naturalmente é
muito longo e é bonitinho mas na prática
a gente sabe como isso é difícil e
chegar no hospital para ser otimizada e
12 horas depois estava dentro de uma uti
recebendo tratamento
e se a visão de rede gente não são super
computadores em séries não são super
manuais são os cérebros insere
trabalhando junto todos eles focados
para tentar ajudar e são ações
relativamente simples até muito simples
mas cujo impacto social é tremendo
principalmente para nós que trabalhamos
em áreas como és países em
desenvolvimento e grandes distâncias
essa é a idéia da rede e geralmente
quando a gente fala sobre isso as
pessoas sempre perguntam isso é
replicável como foi feito eu acho que
isso é replicável acho que pode ser
feito mas a principal lição que nós
aprendemos é que não é somente aporte
financeiro não é somente tecnologia não
é somente conhecimento mas é uma coisa
que realmente vai muito além
o comprometimento das pessoas que se
envolvem a vontade das pessoas de fazer
diferente de se superar de verem o ser
humano de igual para igual independente
de onde eles estão na escala social
acadêmica socioeconômica
dentro disso e esse talvez seja o grande
ponto de se nessa rede legos que talvez
possa ser resumida por essa palavra
certo ea empatia eu entender o problema
do outro eu sentir o problema do outro e
querer verdadeiramente ajudar então
acredito que esse é um trabalho muito
interessante e espero que tenha ficado
um pouquinho dessa idéia pra vocês e que
pelo menos alguns de vocês hoje saiam
daqui dessa sala pensando se no futuro
quando tiverem algum outro problema ao
invés de globalizar uma solução pré
moldada
se vocês não poderiam legalizar as suas
soluções e se a gente não poderia como
tantas outras pessoas em tantos espaços
pequenos do nordeste do brasil começar a
colocar pessoas juntas a colocar cérebro
juntos e criar novas e talvez melhores
soluções para esse tipo de problema com
toda essa alegria que essas pessoas têm
e aqui eu peço licença para o padre e
epi los o futebol inglês chamado de onde
rebate quero o autor original da frase
onde há um desejo há um caminho para
terminar dizendo que com empatia onde é
o desejo encontra-se o melhor caminho
obrigado
[Aplausos]